Oakland is in the building low blood
welcome West Oakland to be exact now
this is what's crazy is I have and I'm
pretty like
like I would say I'm like pretty tapped
in with the Bay Area Music I guess I'm
not all the way tapping because I kind
of found you off of your interviews I
forgot I think I was talking to uh
I was talking to somebody I was talking
a little Russell uh-huh and I was like
yeah like little bloody this dope he's
got a dope platform he's like oh you
don't know from from his his record that
went crazy I was like nah bro right so I
kind of came came like up on you like in
terms of just like you interviewing
people and you having like a dope
platform right right
um thank you I appreciate it and um I'm
glad I started that platform because
that got me indoors that normally
wouldn't have been open from the music
right but uh [__] happens and it runs
hand in hand but now my music career
fires like um no I've been tapped it
tapping in and checking out your [__]
because I followed you and then
um the third world record was the record
yeah yeah one super viral so it's crazy
uh
we recorded that record like 10 years
ago and um it was just on some uh my one
of my partners bolski had went to jail
and um we was hella Maddie went to jail
and at that time
um do you remember little basically of
course he well isn't The [__] Mob
record the same beat so yeah so what
happened was you know we we big little B
fans I don't give up me too I used to
cook [__] Ellen DeGeneres yeah like
yeah so
um
uh [__] Mob Anthem my little brother
rest in peace jellybo he used to always
come by singing that song and when
boskey went to jail we like [__] it we
just recorded the record but we was
playing around bullshitting with the
record and um for the record it's not
mixed or Master like you know so many
Bay Classics are not mix and Masters
yeah it happens it happens a lot shout
out to Dilo right like no hope sounds
like it just they just laid it down and
dropped that [__] but I think Ozzie
said he mixed no gazi said he I think it
was NoHo or um the record with tiger
Dilo one of them that one probably got
mixed yeah but um long story short [__]
we recorded that song Bam and it's
always been like a northern California
hit right but um I don't know what
happened on Tick Tock that [__] just
went crazy it's been going crazy
recently right yeah it's still going
crazy like I don't know I mean you don't
know the source of like who who posted
this source of who posted it I think it
was uh
I don't know some little dude did a
dance to it long story short that [__]
went fire and it's still going and God
is good it's gonna be crazy because I
was like you'll see like old records pop
up and he'd be like damn but that goes
to show you music is timeless for sure
even just like having an independent hit
go like resurface right hell yeah that's
like different like oh yeah um and um
the crazy part about it is uh
it went viral didn't stop didn't it go
viral again like it keeps you know doing
that [__] like Kim Kardashian and
Northwest so I was seeing hella like
um Artie's and Jada and them doing [__]
to us so I'm like oh that's cool I go
um but when I seen Kim K and Northwest
do it wild yeah I'm like okay that's
different Kanye paying attention yeah I
mean I hope so yeah definitely yeah
definitely you know well [__] and that's
independently you that's straight
Independence right independent yeah for
sure
records they don't do that
um so for you like fast forward now
having that kind of happen and having
people kind of come into your catalog
and check out like the newer [__] like
where are you on the music side because
you're so you're doing so much you're
obviously Community leader you're
obviously doing the podcast and still
dropping new music how do you balance
the [__] balance yeah
um
honestly it's the same [__] so uh
with our uh Studio we have a studio
where we film our podcast we also got a
recording studio there you get what I'm
saying so and then it's like I was
popping away with the music way before
the podcast and [__] I just started
doing the podcast and [__] because my
team shout out talker media shout out
bear Jones they were like bro you going
on all these people platforms and you're
blowing that [__] up like people love to
hear you talk like right bro start doing
your own [__] right and they was telling
me this for damn near a year or two
before I said [__] it come on let's try
it and then one day we did it in front
of the first episode people gravitated
towards it and then I had um the people
that reach out like bro I want to come
on your podcast I want to sit down with
you when you sitting at your house at
four in the morning and Marshawn Lynch
call you and like bro what the [__] bro
why you ain't telling me you had a
podcast he just told he just came on the
second time right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he just did it a second time and
it's just like you know people like that
and just talk like bro I rather sit down
with you because [__] [__] you fed a
call you're the culture right [__] you
ain't trying to make no money you ain't
vulture you ain't asking no weird ass
questions you not I'm you're not gonna
have a blood on your podcast or asking
why they Funk with Crips you know you
get what I'm saying like that [__] just
sterile so I'm like [__] I might as well
keep this [__] going so that's what made
me just drop that [__] and low and push
the [__] out the podcast yeah well how
often do you drop is it once a week
um no sometimes it depends like
um sometimes I drop three or four a week
it depends sometimes I won't drop nine
for two weeks it depends on how we
feeling so um it'd be engaged to where
in the garden did eight interviews and
one day got there got to our uh Studio
probably four and we ain't leaving the
three or four in the morning type [__]
and then waking up and being back there
at 12 again like you know I feel like
too it was like a needed uh void filled
in the bay yeah to have like a dope
platform obviously I think if you come
to La you got guys like 80 and T well
doing their things right you know shout
out uh t-rail he uh put me on a no
jumper salute too real for that I
remember that interview yeah that was
one of the early uh t-rell interviews
yeah um no honestly it was the last
interview they did in that day before
they left oh in the old building though
it was in the old building yeah yeah
shout out to you real for that and like
I said uh Tyrell was on there early you
know all his homies I [__] with LA a lot
like bro you gotta get blood on your
[__] you gotta get blood on your [__]
you interviewing all these [__] like
you gotta get blood on your [__] like
you know blood really he really pushed
this [__] and when rap about he really
is that so grab him on your [__] and
when he reached out you know it's all
salute to t-rev he did it